[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon everybody that was quite
an entrance city good outfits that call
for joining me there are some seats here
if you want to fill in a wall side if
you're in the back and won a seat don't
good afternoon thank you all for being
here today I am thrilled just thrilled
to announce the appointment of Victoria
Vicki John as Yale University's next
Director of Athletics physical education
and recreation
so when you hear me speak of an even
more excellent yell that includes my
goal for Yale athletics even more
excellent and Viki is a nationally
respected leader in college athletics
she will advance Yale's reputation for
excellence as she supports our
outstanding intercollegiate and
intramural athletes both important to me
she loves you and is totally committed
to the success of our student-athletes
in every dimension I feel very very
lucky to have her on board everyone
everyone I spoke to during the stretch
process was so positive about Vicky
people love her she's a tough leader
with a great spirit an enormous energy
Vicky embraces Gail's
approach to athletics in keeping with
the tradition of the Ivy League prizing
the development of student-athlete while
being committed to playing at the
highest levels and winning Vicky
believes as I do that a strong athletics
program can help us fulfill yells
mission the mission to educate aspiring
leaders who serve all sectors of society
we share a belief that athletics teach
students how to triumph as well as how
to handle disappointment athletics
helped to develop in students resilience
dedication perseverance teamwork and
leadership she shares Tom's commitment
and my commitment to two people to
students and to every member of our
University and TL
and she recognizes the critical
importance of athletics in bringing us
together as the campus and as an alumni
community serving to reinforce a more
unified young Vicki is coming to Yale
from Colgate University where she has
the vice president and director of
athletics for the past six years she was
a decorated volleyball player as an
undergraduate
she was the captain of the volleyball
team for two years and a four-year
letter winner and helped her team win
the inaugural Patriot League
championship later she served as
Colgate's head volleyball coach guiding
her student-athletes to two Conference
championships and the university's first
NCAA Tournament berth
she's commonly the only individual in
NCAA Division one history to earn both
player and coach of the year in the same
conference in addition to winning
Conference championships in both of
those roles at Colgate Rickey has worked
closely with faculty with students and
with staff to foster a high level of
academic rigor and integrity among
student athletes under her leadership
the student athlete GPA increased every
year and the athletics program produced
a valedictorian and a salutatorian and
it achieved its highest number of dean's
lists recipient Dean's List recipients
she's committed to cultivating respect
within the athletics program while
guiding teams to new levels of success
during her tenure at Colgate the
football team the men's and women's
hockey and soccer teams the men's
lacrosse team and the volleyball team
earned national recognized and
she raised millions of dollars for major
athletic projects including a 97
thousand square foot arena a soccer and
women's lacrosse complex a football
locker room Novation and a new academic
Services Center which was named for very
representing her unwavering commitment
to the student-athlete experience many
other infrastructure projects owe her
for their accomplishment Vicki is a
national advocate for excellence on the
field and in the classroom
she received a three year she served as
a three year president of women leaders
in college sports and as a member of the
Harvard University Board of Overseers a
member of the NCAA Division one Council
she also serves as the vice chair of the
NCAA division one football Oversight
Committee and on the newly created
division 1 football competition
committee Vicki we are so fortunate to
be bringing to yell an individual with
immense expertise and experience from
being a decorated student-athlete to an
award-winning coach and an athletics
leader we are so fortunate to be
bringing you to the Yale community
please join me in extending a warm
bulldog welcome to Vicki
[Applause]
and now Vicki what an honor it is to be
here today I'm just trying to get over
the excitement of having to walk a
handsome Dan to the podium or maybe he
was walking me I first like to take this
opportunity to thank president Salome
Dean Jean and we're not related and the
entire search committee for the trust
and confidence you have placed in me to
be yells next athletic director while I
am incredibly excited about what lies
ahead I would be remiss if I'd not
express my deep gratitude and
appreciation to the entire Colgate
community for embracing me during my
time there as a student-athlete as a
head coach and then most recently as
vice president and director of athletics
in particular I'd like to thank Colgate
Board of Trustees Chairman Dan Hurwitz
and trustee emeritus brain Applegate for
their support and friendship in addition
I like to thank my parents the two
people who taught me about the
life-changing result that can come from
the powerful combination of academics
and ethics
I have to admit it is quite humbling to
be following in the footsteps of one of
Yale's greatest leaders the
longest-serving athletic director in
school history and Yale's greatest fan
Tom Beckett
[Applause]
Tom I promise we will uphold the strong
foundation you dedicated your career to
building and we will honor you by
reaching new heights in the Yale
tradition of creating leaders through
athletics and when you spend your entire
career in higher education you dream of
coming to a place to work with student
athletes of Yale caliber my vision for
yellow athletics is threefold
to enhance the university's winning
culture and commitment to
competitiveness to support the
unparalleled
education of leaders and continue to
change the world through that same
powerful combination of academics and
sport that my parents first shared with
me I am a firm believer that when you
foster and expect excellence success and
positive results will follow I have long
admired years commitment to not only
striving to reach the highest standard
but also in setting that standard as
president salva often points out to Yale
student athletes we bask in your
reflected glory you and your
achievements are at cause for all of us
to feel an incredible sense of pride and
a reason for all of us to come together
as a community I look forward to
enhancing the success of our programs
celebrating even more Ivy League
championships and always always beating
Harvard
at last week's World Economic Forum Jack
Ma Alabama Group CEO advocated for an
approach to education that will
differentiate humans from the
intelligent machines of the future core
leadership skills like character values
independent thinking teamwork and caring
for others are critical to society's
future he emphasized that children learn
these skills through art music and
sports the many intramural recreational
sports club sports and athletic
facilities that benefit our community
are a crucial platform for developing
these qualities at Yale we will continue
our focus on preparing and educating
leaders through this holistic approach
over the next several months I look
forward to listening to you building
relationships with you and then going to
work with you renowned poet and Yale
graduate mark strand once said the
future is always beginning now that
seems especially true to me today I am
excited to be a part of Yale's future
I am honored and humbled to be our
athletic director
bula-bula
[Applause]
Thank You Vicki
that was fantastic I have to express a
little bit of gratitude myself I really
appreciate so many of you in this very
room today provided input into this
search members of the Yale community
including coaches and staff and faculty
and students and alumni all gave us the
benefit of your wisdom and ideas as we
searched for Yale's next athletic
director thank you for that I also thank
the eleven members of the athletic
directors search Advisory Committee
chaired by Marvin Chun the Dean of Yale
College for providing an invaluable
service and getting it done on time and
on budget that was good work that was
good work
and to Tom Becket truly a Yale legend
and a good friend I thank you from the
bottom of my heart for twenty four years
of outstanding service to this
university we'll have a chance to do
this in a more formal way and more
elaborate way later in the semester but
this spring with your retirement the
retirement of Yale's biggest fan it will
represent a landmark in the history of
Yale athletics Tom's legacy especially
his unwavering dedication to Yale's
student-athletes
will be carried on very very well
by Vicki and I'm glad we'll be
celebrating it later in the semester I'm
also pleased that Tom will be helping
out Yale in various ways in the time
ahead and we will all continue to enjoy
his presence and working with him we
love you Tom thank you for everything
so I I know the band is still with us on
the steps and this is your big cue I am
going to ask them to to play something
where we can all sing along so how could
a big Bulldog moment like this pass how
could we even consider it complete
without us standing up and singing well
Bulldog Bulldog Bow Wow Wow
alright you all got the lyrics let's do
it
fan can you kick this off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we invite you to enjoy the reception
thank you for being here
you